the Ukrainian Ministry of Defense has
put a complete news blackout on events
in the Curson region and that almost
always means that there is some big
offensive uh under underway uh certainly
the Russian reaction indicates that that
is the case they're talking about moving
out of Curson region and it looks as if
they may be preparing either to withdraw
or to fight for it we don't really know
what's going on inside the region but we
can see quite a lot of what's going on
around it the ukrainians have mounted a
whole series of air attacks they're
known in the in the jargon of seat
suppression of enemy air defenses
they've been attacking air defense sites
Russian air defense sites all around the
region and that's almost always a
Prelude to events on the ground taking
on a greater Tempo Ben Wallace the
British defense secretary flew to the
United States to see his counterpart
Lloyd Austin that was all at short
notice not expected that's quite unusual
that they wanted to talk directly about
something that's going to happen next
and the Royal Air Force has been taking
a an interest in all of this this is the
rc-135 known as joint River it's a
surveillance aircraft and the rc-135
this is probably from 51 Squadron based
at Waddington it was out over the Black
Sea yesterday doing little figures of
eight protected by a couple of typhoon
fighters who are there to look after it
and all it does is Hoover up electronic
intelligence it just listens to
everything including the phone calls of
of troops on the ground but it gets
absolutely everything
the ministry of Defense would not
normally take this amount of trouble
over an area unless it thought that
something was happening undoubtedly the
battle for cursing is now on this is the
most important strategic objective of
all of the offensives which the
ukrainians have launched since July this
year if they succeed it will be a
tremendous victory for them if they
don't succeed it will be a terrific
setback we'll probably find out quite
soon which of those is the case